[Music]
hello friends this is Kevin Rose I'm
here with mr. Tim Ferriss welcome to
episode number 947 of the random show
listen your flare man what what happened
yeah I'm just bust is that good I'm just
busting your balls it was good but you
looked off to the side like Rain Man
which I liked on the video oh did I yeah
yeah but I like that [ __ ] I have my
ten-year meet up anniversary with Daria
last night is artificial ten years
together from our first date I should
say and yeah had some wine
I hate wine yeah you know this is it's a
love/hate thing so tell me about it tell
me about it first of all congratulations
because ten years is no joke that's huge
yeah it is huge it has been a crazy ride
with lots of lessons learned
you know kids all kinds of insanity
now it's appropriate that you would have
I'm not sure if you're willing to go
into this I don't see why not but it's
appropriate that you guys would have
wine last night because maybe you could
talk about one of your first dates and
how wine flayed into that yeah I mean I
basically walked into this bar I I had
well I should back up so will here's
who's the the quick I don't want to
advise spend an hour on this but here's
the quick little overview I met Daria
through Twitter of all places yeah
and we met on Twitter because I was very
fortunate enough to talk f Williams the
then CEO to add me to the suggested user
list this is when Twitter had like 15
people on the suggested user list so I
was one of the default recommended
people to a lot of different folks so
this is before they used algorithms for
all that stuff so anyway Dorian's have
following me
she retweets me on on something that I'd
mentioned dr. Andrew Weil she retweets
that I see here a little twenty by
twenty icon I'm like who's this little
sexy little icon you have the Green the
green cutoff shirt
probably back in the probably that
sounds about right
and so I I clicked through on it and you
know she said she's in the wine into
food you know she's a neuroscientist I'm
like check check check that sounds
amazing
we should go hang out and so ended up
damming her we met up at a bar I walked
in saw her was blown away and
immediately realized I needed
a substance to kind of like dump my
nerves a little bit oh I think a dumber
down so she would succumb to your charms
pretty much I think a little bit of both
actually so I ended up just walking up
and bought a whole bottle of wine and
apparently she thought that was a pretty
ballsy thing she's like who just buys a
bottle of wine but I don't know I just
felt like we were just gonna sit there
for a while and I knew we had a lot of
overlap and even if we were just friends
like we'd have a lot to talk about
yeah Cheryl you know that was the first
date and I say dumber down because for
people who don't know Daria is razor
sharp and extremely intellectual very
well-read and a scientist so she's she's
extremely extremely strong in the
hardware brain Department yeah she's
really good at call me on my [ __ ]
which is great it's important super
important it is I think that's what good
friends do too sometimes yeah no doubt
dude yeah yeah so what are we gonna do -
on this episode you had mentioned you
want to reflect back on the last 10
years right I was thinking we could talk
about resolutions we could talk yeah for
2020 or anything that we've thought
about for 2020 and also look back over
the last 10 years which is crazy for me
to even contemplate I was looking at
some of the landmarks along the way and
it simultaneously seems not long ago at
all and a hundred years ago well dude I
would love to continue this little theme
that we started on because I know you're
fans always like to hear this stuff is
like talk to me about your last 10 years
of relationships no I know that's tough
but like a lesson lessons learned like
for let me just start off with a
30-second version my lessons learned are
find someone that you're always on the
same team with so knowing that you're
together in this versus fighting someone
or having to like you know have your own
side is a big one and the second thing
for me was therapy like therapy and what
got me here today in a very happy
positive relationship is Daria and I at
multiple times went to a therapist and
sat down and had a third party kind of
analyzed and helped us work through some
ins issues so that we could figure out
how to be on the same team but I'd love
to hear like I mean I've known you
personally for a long time so I've seen
you through all types of ladies
oh yeah we have we've mutually assured
destruction on this one if we don't wait
why the res note go nuclear but we have
seen we've watched each other with many
different relationships and trials and
tribulations and learning learning
moments teachable moments I would say
that looking back there are a few things
that are very present for me now that
may have come through some really bad
decisions in the past and also just just
kind of mileage right I mean you start
to realize better what you need over
time also yeah
polarity number one I would say is
extremely important and what do you mean
by Blair we could spend a lot of time
discussing various ways to consider
polarity but what I mean by that is
let's just say you have a sliding scale
and this is probably gonna get me in all
sorts of trouble so for people listening
I don't care if you're martian
us-japanese male/female trans in between
there there are different types of
polarity and I'm going to use probably a
heteronormative language so if you want
to crucify me go for it but let's just
say you have a slider that goes out this
way and right in the middle you have not
as related to an Anatomy but rather
characteristics what let's arbitrarily
call a pure androgyny in the center okay
and then you have feminine
characteristics and let's just assume
for the sake of argument that each
person is going to decide for them what
that means but feminine characteristics
this direction masculine characteristics
this direction so you have sort of and
then
what I have observed for myself and also
in a lot of my friends is that it's it's
sometimes very helpful to find someone
who is equally far away from that middle
point in the opposite direction right so
if you have someone who is maybe hyper
excessively developed in terms of
masculine traits however you want to
look at that very often they're gonna
pair well from what I've seen with
someone who is as far in the opposite
direction
and likewise like this right and there
are there are books that just got that
discuss this I read the way of the
superior man a hundred years ago by
David data which talks a lot about this
and I don't agree with everything in
that book but I do think polarity
maintaining polarity enhancing polarity
which can be done through any number of
different practices or reframes that I
think is very important for maintaining
a relationship where there is intense
attraction and healthy a healthy sex
life for it for instance right I think
that's very important is this one two
would be and this relates to what you
said having structure for cultivating
the relationship that could come in the
form of therapy it could come in the
form of having it say a date night once
a week having a couples day once a
quarter which I do with my girlfriend
where we spend a day talking very
candidly about the things we like the
things were afraid of sort of fears
desires boundaries negotiating new
things testing new things setter and we
spend an entire day doing that it's
blocked out and it's known in advance
that's gonna be once a quarter we have
different types of say the systems if
you want to call it that for cultivating
the garden before it's in trouble does
that meant that make sense I think that
in it for a long time all was well until
there was a Code Red and things would
devolve people wouldn't say things they
needed to say
resentment might build and then
something would explode and yes then
everyone is firefighting trying to
figure it out and by that point emotions
have run so high elbows are coming out
and it and it doesn't mean both sides
but very often elbows would come out
from someone and it would just devolve
very quickly so how do you handle when
you when you have these because everyone
has disagreements and they have these
little things that may rub them the
wrong way when you're in a relationship
and there's this balance between you
know taking everything personally and
just you know constantly responding back
to your partner being like I didn't like
this I didn't like that it didn't like
this and then it becomes this like
little nitpicky yeah type of
relationship versus you know some of it
you may want to just bundle up and
discuss at a later point in time like
how do you know when something reaches a
certain threshold to where you bring it
up with your significant other yeah I
have fun and I don't I don't mention my
girlfriend's name because the Internet's
[ __ ] crazy so I like to try to
protect her you guys are both public
figures so it's part of the game in a
sense for you guys but in any sense or
in any case I should say it that's why
I'm referring to my girlfriend is my
girlfriend but she and I generally will
batch and I think that's in large part
because I'm very sensitive I'm a
sensitive guy in a lot of ways and I
don't use sensitive I used to view that
word in a very negative light a very
negative connotation because we think oh
he's so sensitive meaning he or she
takes everything personally but I had it
one of my closest friends who you've met
actually before asked me maybe two years
ago he said when did you know that you
were really sensitive and the question
really confused me and I'm gonna get
back to the relationship and timing
question what I realized is my
instrumentation in certain ways is just
very very sensitive it's almost like a
scale it just has more decimal points
for certain things and I find a lot of
stimulation overwhelming and for that
reason so at a young age I learned how
to turn that off or numb that
sensitivity but I don't want to do that
in a relationship out so I've over time
in the last 10 years also learned that
turning off or compartmentalizing
emotionally is short term effective long
term very destructive coming back to the
timing question so I'm still very
sensitive to having things I might
perceive as criticism or suggestions
that require me to make decisions coming
at me at like 3 p.m. on a weekday if I'm
in the middle of some type of phone call
or project or writing whatever it might
be and there are there are some timing
solutions to that they're also
structural solutions right so my
girlfriend tends to work at home and I
work downtown I have a separate place
that I use for work that in and of
itself solves a lot of problems and
right and it's in its and you don't have
to figure it all out being within 20
feet of each other at all times like
that is a perfectly valid answer right
so that's one number two is that we will
block out time they will block out two
hours or three hours in a given night
I'm making this up but let's just say
once every two weeks where we'll do
batching and the format of that is not
what we tested in the beginning which
was like let's voice all of our
complaints but when we started with that
in other words this like litany of
charges against each other in the
beginning it it poisoned the well and
turned into very unpleasant experience
for both of us that we didn't look
forward to right we kind of dreaded
doing it and
my girlfriend suggested a much better
format some like them
good news takes care of itself let's
just like tell me the bad news
turns out yeah that's also pretty
counterproductive in a lot of cases so
we start with what we think the other
person is doing really well since the
last batching session and what they're
paying attention to and what we'd like
then we will talk about what we think we
are doing well personally as a partner
and then what we would like more of and
the phrasing is really important right
it's not what you're [ __ ] up it's
what I would love more of so sort of
positive reinforcement if we're thinking
about it like dog training right you're
trying to shape a behavior instead of
whacking the dog with a newspaper you're
giving a little Scooby Snack to push
them in the right direction when they
get something approximately right and
that's the format so we do that and
what's important to us at least may be
important to me important to both of us
as we take notes so if there are
commitments that are made or important
points that are brought up we have
something that we can then refer to
before the next backing session and we
can see where homework wasn't done yeah
and if some that sounds really powerful
just to have that I mean that I like the
way that you structured that because I
could see very quickly how that could
just be a negative kind of [ __ ] if
you don't have that structure around it
yeah yeah and I'm and I'm extremely
lucky that my girlfriend's a very clean
fighter
that's something I've also learned is
extremely important because the good
times are the good times but yes I heard
someone I don't remember who said this
but the quote is not that adversity
builds character but adversity reveals
character and you really want to know
that your partner can navigate rough
emotional waters when things are
difficult and not immediately pull out a
gun and shoot you in the face yeah I
mean I'm very fortunate there too that's
something that Daria has taught me a lot
is that it just were you coming from in
this discussion like where if it's a
from a place of I want us to be
stronger and better together and we are
on the same team trying to solve the
same problem yeah then it's a it's it's
very constructive versus of being about
tearing down someone yeah there's a
there's a framework that the conscious
leadership group uses Jim Detmer diana
chapman and so on then i like quite a
lot i was introduced to their book which
i think is a 15 commitments of conscious
leadership by Dustin Moskovitz a long
time ago a couple years ago and they
have this concept of being above the
line or below the line and I'll let
people look it up if they're interested
but it's a very easy way to check in
with yourself or with someone else to
see how they are engaging in a
conversation or how you're engaging in a
conversation and if it's likely to go
sideways or if it's more likely to be
constructive and so the phrasing they
use is above the line or below the line
and I have found all of these helpful
and I think in part what I'm trying to
say is that what what's important is not
that you use exactly someone else's
system or someone else's habits but that
you think about developing and using
systems or structure of some type
mmm-hmm yeah I mean so many people out
there and I was one of these people as
well just believe that if you find the
right person everything will be fine you
know I was always like looking for that
perfect person and it just doesn't exist
I know like we're unique creatures and
so you know the second you can realize
that and then you realize well I do need
a framework for this you're just gonna
be in such a better place what what
resources or practices have you found
helpful in your relationship aside from
the therapy and when you were doing the
therapy when you found it most impactful
how often were you doing it how long
were the sessions was there a particular
type of therapy what did that look like
yeah basically on the therapy side it
was about an hour long session and we
would go once a week and we did that for
a couple months and really that was her
position is like I'm not a mediator here
I'm
to give you and teach you tools so that
you can go off and do this on your own
you know this isn't about you know the
chiropractor method where you just have
to keep them back for one more session
your back will be fixed you know so she
was actually dari isn't that right now I
might keep telling her stuff going to
the chiropractor yeah you gotta make
sure they're not you know adjusting you
in a week and then putting it back to
how it was the next week and then just
right exactly but you know once we had
those skills that I and I think a lot of
it came down to the language we use with
each other and then also just stopping
before the conversation even begins and
realizing in both acknowledging that the
conversation we're gonna have is so that
we can figure out the best path forward
because we both deeply love each other
you know and we want to find a solution
to this and so that kind of just like
just starting up from that if you can
both get in that mindset it just really
diffuses things right up right off the
bat and that's that's like 90% of it
your language I am embarrassed how long
it has taken me as someone who is
supposedly a writer to pay close
attention to the language I use with my
partner and I've always been semi aware
of the language that I'm using but I've
very often become impatient and wanted
to cut to the chase in conversations
where that is kind of like lighting your
hair on fire and then looking for the
fire extinguisher it's it's backfire is
more than it helps and nonviolent
communication has been a door that
opened a lot to me in the sense that
there's a framework for non-violent
communication people can look this up
the audio book
of the same name was recommend to be by
neil strauss initially and what it made
clear to me is that if you phrase things
such that you are taking full
responsibility for your experience and
your emotions
it really disarms people and helps to
avoid a lot of head-butting and
defensiveness for example one of the
phrases that my girlfriend uses a lot
there two things she does that I think
are very remarkable at least that's
that's that's how I felt and how I still
feel number one is she will very often
preface any type of criticism with the
story or something as bothering her
she'll say the story that I'm creating
in my own head is that you
dot-dot-dot right you did X because you
wanted me to feel Y and therefore it
hurt my feelings but it's fundamentally
different from saying you did X to make
me feel Y right my response to - the
first is very soft and I'm engaged and I
listen versus the second the second
thing she does which i think is very
mature and that i've copied is there are
times when i'll ask her a question maybe
we've had an argument or what or maybe
simply it's been a difficult day I might
ask her what's wrong what's on your mind
and she'll say hmm I have a lot of my
mind but I'm gonna spend some time
processing it I'm feeling a little tired
or a little upset and I feel like if we
talk right now I'm just gonna make a
mess of things so let's talk later so
she will veto my attempt to engage if
she feels like she is emotionally in a
place where the content or tone of the
conversation might take a sideways and
then next morning she but great can we
spent together can we put some time on
the calendar to talk maybe we can go out
to dinner and get in the calendar then
she's in a better place after a good
night's sleep some exercise then we talk
and I have
as someone who has often been in a rush
to rip off the band-aid with everything
found that very wise and really really
effective so I've applied that not just
in my interactions with her but with
other people also right if they call me
for a big conversation about something
that's sensitive and I'm exhausted maybe
I drank too much coffee I'm a little
twitchy then I will use effectively the
exact same phrasing to reschedule yeah
that's brilliant
I've never thought of that and as it's
like it's makes complete sense I mean
just hitting pause for a moment to
recalibrate I think sleep plays a big
role in a lot of this stuff like I will
feel completely different about a
subject the next morning when I woke up
and had a good night's sleep you know oh
yeah yeah well that's that's on my it's
on my list of things that's yeah
certainly at you know I have all these
lists in front of me but how have you
been thinking about either 2020 or the
last decade because I've been spending a
lot of time thinking about this I'm not
done thinking about it but what is
anything that comes to mind in terms of
looking forward to 2020 or looking back
from 2010 to 2020 for you yeah I mean I
think when I look back I try to think
about a couple things what were some of
the big aha moments that I had that when
I look at him like gosh wish I would
have done that sooner but you know
there's not much you can do because they
happen when they happen and that's fine
and then you know what's worked well and
what do I want to continue forward with
and the continue to bring forward into
you know this new decade and then also
what are some of the things that I
totally missed the boat on that I need
to go and especially now given my age
now that I'm you know well into might
well not well into my 40s but I'll be 43
this year what do I want to address to
set me up for the long term and so
that's that's how I've kind of been
putting these things into buckets what
what do you have in any of those
categories I'm particularly interested
in the last one but I'm interested in
all of them and need any any examples
that you can give
yeah I mean I think that I wrote down a
handful of things when I was when I was
kind of doing my prep for the new year
looking back on the last decade the one
thing that I didn't do soon enough was
admit to really to myself and to others
that you know I didn't know certain
things and I think the the quicker you
are to come forward with the fact that
there is a hole in your knowledge the
quicker that hole will be filled and I
think that you know oftentimes I tried
to cover that up because you know you
get in certain situations you know when
I was working it let's say as a partner
over at Google Ventures or you know and
you're working with people that that
seem to be a little bit more
well-rounded than you in certain areas
and there's this kind of like fear of oh
maybe they'll find out that I really
don't know as much as they think I do or
you know and you have these little holes
and it could be in all different aspects
of life and I've just I've kind of like
given up on that in the last couple
years and just been like screw it like
if I don't know something I'm going to
come out and just say so and just try
and pick it up from from mentors so this
was turning people rather than treating
them as like someone that's going to
judge me
is to someone that I can learn from and
that has been just something that in you
know probably the last few years I've
gotten a lot better at but earlier in
the decade I just really avoided and hid
from people so that was you always been
really good at that though you're the
master of learning new things and
admitting when you don't know something
oh thanks for saying that I thought that
is I mean I've got plenty of plenty of
weaknesses but I do think that I am for
whatever reason very good at very
quickly saying I have no idea what that
is or who that is yeah and I think the
podcast has helped quite frankly because
people bring stuff up and I'm like if I
pretend not along like I know what's
going on this could get really ugly so
they're like do you see this movie I'm
not gonna be like oh yeah great movie
and then I'm like oh I'm gonna get calls
on this so I've become faster at saying
I have no idea who that person is where
do you think your holes are right now
like if in your kind of like I mean cuz
I know you have dabbled in so many
different things
we share that common interest like where
do you think like gosh I really wish I
was a little deeper in this given area
well it's an area that I've spent a lot
of time studying and focusing on in the
last six to nine months which is saying
no and creating rules and policies that
allow you to say no easily or more end
or more quickly right so I think I've
over you been practicing that for a
while though cuz you've been saying no
to investing for a very long time yeah I
haven't been able to get you to invest
in a deal in like ten years yeah yeah
it's and that is in the result of that
or I should say the reason that is
something I've been able to do is that I
set a policy and made a public
announcement and I want to say 2015 that
I was stopping startup investing and so
you can analyze very easily actually why
it's easy for me to do that versus say
no to some other things and a commitment
that I've wanted to make for 2020 and
Beyond and this was informed by a Seth
Godin blog post actually that I put my
newsletter and final Friday about not
trying harder but creating better
systems and rules instead and there are
a number of anecdotes in that that
really drive the point home it's very
short piece people can find it it's one
of the most popular on his entire blog
of his ten million posts it he has so
I've been looking for and I know you're
a fan of the book essentialism and Greg
McEwan yeah was on the podcast not that
long ago the filter that he uses that
I'm trying to also use more is where can
I make one decision that removes a
hundred or a thousand or ten thousand
decisions so the startup retirement is a
great example it's public it's something
I can point to its accountable or I can
be held accountable it's not personal
right it's been depersonalized
and that has removed so much stress in
my life it is it is hard to overstate
how what do you think but where did that
come from because when I think about the
things that I've seen you say yes to in
the past they have been these epic
things like adventures travel like new
different types of you know things from
doing sauna and ice training or you name
it like you've done so many crazy body
hacks and you know that was all because
you said yes to everything like so where
are you saying no Tunis yeah it's well I
should say that the what's important to
note there is I thought you were gonna
mention startups but it applies in the
same way is that the the there's a
survivorship bias in the sense that what
I say yes to is visible or my friends at
least might be aware of it but behind
the scenes I'm saying no to almost
everything and I'll give you an example
of something that I've been thinking
about so first I have an announcement
already on the blog and so on which says
I do not do book Bert book blurbs look
Blair Maroubra little book blurbs and
that was a decision I made because I
didn't want to have to pick and choose
among friends which could create all
sorts of bad blood and and drama that I
didn't want my life and therefore I
decided on a blanket nobler policy
nonetheless I still get sent dozens of
books every week by publishers who have
put me on their spam mail lists I have
dozens of unsolicited books that get
sent to me and I have many do I get the
same thing I don't know how to turn it
off yeah it's like spam it is so I'm
going to maybe do some some public
shaming with these publishers so
publishers if you're listening please
take me off your mailing lists I have
not asked ever to be on a single one but
I won't hurt the authors don't worry
about that I'm not gonna shame the
authors because I don't think mister
it's sitting near random books like
unsolicited that's a [ __ ] such a
[ __ ] but the what I realized is I'm
the the nobler policy isn't enough it's
not upstream enough to try to address
the problem because I'll still
tons of books and if you do the math
right you read the tail-end by Tim urban
you realize I might only be able to read
I don't know a few hundred books before
I bite the dust let's just call it if
we're looking at good books that take a
long time to digest some of the classics
let's say you do not have the luxury of
reading books that you are not in full
stoke about and part of finding books
that are more likely to invoke full
stoke is looking at books that have
stood the test of some time doesn't need
to be a hundred years but it could
certainly be five years ten years
something like that
so one of the commitments that I'm
making and this is this is the first
time I'm talking about it for 2020 is
I'm not gonna read any new books and new
books means no books published in 2020
I'm not gonna read any books published
in 2020 and that will immediately I'm
gonna write a post about that it will be
public and on spec hey that's the policy
so for whatever reason once making that
announcement I will be ridiculed and
called a hypocrite and give an unending
[ __ ] from my loving audience because
that's what they should do if i betray
that right so I have to be very very
thoughtful about making that type of
decision but that removes so much of
like the FOMO the neo mania the Keeping
Up with mentality that I think that
could really really really return a lot
of dividends so that's one what aligning
things I want I want to call out and I'm
curious to you know we can the thing I
reason I like talking about this is like
we we know each other pretty well and I
like to like poke in a little bit
further
hook away the one thing I've realized
with you is you in and correct me if I'm
wrong or what what how you feel about
this I'm curious to see okay there's a
lot of what a song it's not it's not bad
I when I think about you you have when I
first met you you were relatively
unknown you know in that you didn't have
a big following that's right you had
your book coming out and you know people
were excited about
but you know nothing compared to what
you have today no my mom a few friends
read my blog that was about it right so
I'm curious like when I hear you say
things about like you know publishers
are sending me too many books like and
III want to make sure not to do blurbs
and things like that it feels to me like
you've been bombarded with like too much
to where you feel overwhelmed yeah it's
like everybody wants something from Tim
like the number of times that people
that have like pinged me and be like
dude you know Tim can you send him this
damn ball of law it must just be anxiety
provoking into some sense and that
you're being pulled in so many different
directions it's like in a way I mean
you're not like celebrity like you know
you walk down the street I'm sure people
do recognize you but not to the sense
that not like a friend massive movie
star or Brad Pitt or something like that
right but does that is that true and is
that starting to like does that bother
you is that governor your skin a little
bit it feels like it's a lot for you to
hand it's a lot I as someone who is also
taking the armor off of a lot of these
sensitivities because I want to
cultivate them instead of pushing them
underwater it's a challenge to do that
while simultaneously being bombarded
with so much stuff for sure I mean I was
I was pulling at my phone just to look
at unread email 618 thousand nine
hundred and fifty two holy crap all
right then I have two hundred and
seventy I've to be seeing the hundred
and eighty seven hundred text messages
right so I'm ninety nine notifications
on asana it goes on and on but the point
being I don't expect much sympathy
because these are taxes that I pay for
also a wide range of different types of
access and so on that I do have from
yeah private jets no private jet there's
no private jet
I'd like to use yours when it's idle
I'll take your private jet
I'm happy to cover the the beverage cost
these but it is it's it is challenging
from an energetic management perspective
so I find as I get older and looking
back at the last decade and looking
forward to 2020 that time management is
important but time management doesn't
matter unless you have a tension
management right because you can stare
at a screen and have blocked out two
hours and if your mind is wandering all
over the place you're going to hit with
push notifications you can't focus it is
rendered useless let's say see if time
management of tension management and
then if you even have I'm sorry have
time attention and then even if you have
attention and these are related but if
you are lethargic you haven't slept well
or you have been depleted from making
too many decisions mm-hm
you are going to make poor decisions or
the likelihood of making bad decisions
is really high and I well there's also
prioritization of things at that point
right yeah I need to know how to
prioritize certain things otherwise you
could spend time on the wrong things and
attention on the wrong things right so I
mean it could be a Zen Zen well well it
could be Zen but it could be a Venn
diagram with say five or six
interlocking circles and you ready for
that sweet spot and a big part of that
is energy management the only or one of
the best tools I have found for that is
looking at your inbound and your
projects in terms of categories looking
at as I did just recently my last year
looking at energetic peaks and energetic
troughs like what robbed me of energy
the types of things not single things
single things can be helpful with the
types of things where they speaking
engagements were they long conversations
with lawyers were they you name it
spending too much time in cities taxes
taxes K 1 K 1 off the K ones love them
love those K ones herding cattle of
those K ones yeah all of that what are
the categories of things that have
depleted your energy and what are the
categories of things that have given you
energy and so what were those for you
I'm curious especially the giving energy
side keeping energy side
extended time in nature for sure is so
you'd like the forest bathing stuff and
yeah I just spent two weeks in Utah and
spent almost the entire time with at
least an hour to in the mountains every
day and it was incredible I mean
incredibly recharging I was getting a
lot of activity every day because that
is certainly interrelated with sleep
quality sleep onset and so on lots of
activity exposure to Sun and so on made
a huge difference and I came back to I
love Austin but it's funny how these
these shifts can be so relative if I go
to New York City and then I come back to
Austin I I get off the plane and let out
a huge sigh of relief oh my god thank
God my blood pressure drops 20 points
and it's extremely relaxing but going
from the secluded mountains of Utah to
downtown Austin around rush hour
I found completely overwhelming so I've
been very very tired for the last few
days since I got you're gonna be at a
cave I'm going you talk about being a
cave yeah so I thought that's one that I
find very energizing number two would be
creative work before problem-solving or
or managing anything or anyone
so having time blocked out in the
morning to do some type of creative work
it doesn't have to be writing along blog
post or a chapter it doesn't have to be
a painting it could just be taking a
photograph on a hike to sheriff on
Instagram right but something that is
productive in the most literal sense
like it's producing something that in
some fashion uses a creative muscle I
find that sets an emotional tone for
hours afterwards or the entire day
afterwards so it's really more important
than I would have expected to happen
that there are there are lots of other
things but what about yourself
yeah I mean for me well and you me just
mean in terms of things they energize me
yeah we're thinking about 2020 things
you want to do more of verses or things
you want to do less of yeah I've picked
some very specific things one of them is
no BPA or plastic this year so I'm not I
will not drink a beverage out of any
type of tin can they're all lined with
BPA on the inside so and no plastic
containers so I'm using all glass for
anything that I drink out of and so
that's been a big thing for me I just
kind of want to get away from plastics
in general aside from that core strength
I throw my back out is old and lame as
it sounds a couple times over the last
six months probably carrying kids too
much but I so I've been getting more
into I've been doing PT some physical
therapy around that also getting back
into Pilates and then Peter Tia who
you've got on the show multiple times he
recommends a system called dynamic
neuromuscular stabilization DNS DNS and
so have you heard about this at all you
know I have read of it that's that's a
tough acronym issues for the internet
but yes yes that's right so so that's
something that Peters been into over the
last you know probably year plus and I'm
starting to get into as well so really
excited about kind of building that
foundation you know Peter has this thing
where he talks about the centenarian
Olympics like what do you want to be
able to do when you're a hundred like
you want to be able to get out of a pool
without like you know climbing steps and
like so I really I think now is the time
in our life where we could set ourselves
up for that that future so I really want
to start taking that seriously the next
thing is a big one for me and that is
really tracking both well mostly my
drinking over time so I want to be very
mindful about how much alcohol I'm
consuming and so one of the things I did
is I worked with the folks over at zero
the intermittent fasting app that that I
started a couple years ago there's a
whole team around that now and they
built an app called les le SS and so
that just launched on January 1st and it
helps you it's completely free there's
no ads or anything like
that but it just allows you to track all
of your alcohol consumption and you can
set maximum amounts of drinks per week
you could see your week over week month
over month progress and it's just a
great kind of like beautiful little
calendar to track and eventually compare
with friends so we could be able to have
you know of like a friend group and see
who's drinking what but it's there's
something there's some accountability
there that could be pretty interesting
so they started off by me and a buddy my
buddy Mike Mays are just tracking all
this stuff in a spreadsheet and we just
had it in a Google sheet but it was a
pain in the ass to kind of put in new
new figures every day by opening up a
spreadsheet so now we have it in a
little app form so that's a big piece of
it also I've been getting into home
automation a lot for my house so I
really have finally think that home
automation is is is here and it not in
the way I thought it was gonna be but
I've been starting to mess around with a
lot of that stuff just to set up
routines for my house to consume less
energy and and really just coordinate
different things around the house
get-get bring more music into my life
and so part of that is just making it
super simple to kind of like play and
automate throughout the house yeah I was
thinking about this call and this
conversation and took all sorts of notes
and when I look over it I mean a lot of
this all comes back to matically to
energy awareness and energy management
and looking for at least in my case some
of the energy drains that you're simply
or I'm simply unaware of or have been
unaware of for a long time right and I
had Jerry Colonna
you may know the name the coach with the
spider tattoo Bible he was the name of
the podcast but he's does exact coach
work with all sorts of CEOs and so on
and he had a series of questions that
really struck me that I've revisited a
lot since my conversation with him and I
did over new years and I'm still looking
very closely and I'll paraphrase these
aren't going to be perfect
wordings but roughly the questions are
how am i complicit in creating the
conditions I say I don't want mm-hmm
right so how yeah how am I actually very
perhaps subconsciously but nonetheless
very actively creating the conditions
that I [ __ ] and moan about right mm-hmm
that's one the other is or there are
three others you know what needs to be
said that isn't being said and another
way to phrase that would be what am I
not saying that needs to be said that's
actually a huge one for me and I'll come
back to that what's being said that I'm
not hearing I think that's very helpful
for me at least in the context of a
relationship and what am i saying that's
not being heard I don't I don't feel too
focused on that one but what needs to be
said that isn't being said I think that
from a very young age for whatever
reason or a number of reasons I have
protected a lot of people who have
inflicted harm on me and that the goal
is not to make 2020 of the year a
vengeance ah but rather to recognize at
least for myself I've had I've had a
number and by a number I mean probably
six to eight very uncomfortable
conversations in the last two weeks are
these relatives or friends or what would
I cross the board across the board so
these could be people I've worked with
for a long time could be family could be
close friends and by uncomfortable I
don't mean confrontational necessarily
so some of these are talking to people
about episodes or issues or old wounds
that were never fully cleared does that
make sense
mm-hmm and trying to do so in a way
based on all the wonderful schooling
I've had from my girlfriend and I mean
that very sincerely in communication
doing it in a way where everyone comes
away from the conversation ideally
feeling better but doing it first and
foremost to say what you feel you need
to say and recognizing that you cannot
control the response of the other person
so not going in with any
hope or expectation of how someone will
respond but simply to clear the air and
do you think that's because you're
feeling the burden of that 100% psyche
under grab these things that are
unsettled basically and you're like I
need to like just like have this release
it basic I mean you release that by
having a conversation with yeah and some
of these things are months old summer
years old some are decades old and it
could also be on the flip side things
that are very positive but for instance
reaching out to mentors who I never
properly affect you know people who
really helped me it's kind of saved me
in a way during high school years
reaching out and if I get voicemail
leaving a really heartfelt thank you for
all the help that they gave me that at
the time I was just too young I don't
want to blame it on youth the
self-absorbed may be caught up in my own
[ __ ] to realize just how valuable they
were and how much thought they put in to
helping me that type of thing and it's
been so freeing I have to say so those
questions or questions that I want to
pay in addition to other questions a lot
more attention to in 2020 because
there's been such a process for me of
unburdening and I don't know if you've
had this experience but let's just say
you have a backpack and it's full of
[ __ ] that you've been carrying around
for months right there's just stuff that
sits in there could be like oh yeah the
ball I think I'm gonna roll my feet out
on and the extra battery and the this
and the book and the notepad and this
and that and then one day you're like I
okay well I'll take a new backpack and
you just stick in like what you need
like a laptop you walk around you're
like oh my god now my back doesn't hurt
and you just didn't realize because the
new normal was carrying around all that
[ __ ] that suddenly became your new
basis right it became your became your
new reference points so for me having
these conversations started off as an
experiment and I say that's the big
takeaway or one of the big takeaways
from the last ten years for me is the
value of viewing things like this as
short-term experiment
but I didn't expect these conversations
to have the huge exhale and relief of
tension and the persistence of that
feeling that ended up being the case
it's been it's been really remarkable
I've been very impressed and relieved
with that so that's awesome and did you
ever do any of this well I'll give an
example a friend of mine sent me a
really nice note a couple months ago
that was a handwritten note that he
spent the time to thank me for something
and I just read it I was like wow that
was like a really thoughtful thing to do
you know and also I know there's also
power and even writing notes to people
that are no longer here you know if
someone's passed away and you have
something you want to say doing that as
well have you done any of that or has
just been mostly just like in-person
coffees and phone calls and things like
that it's been mostly voice and in part
because I've had I think fear and
hesitation around using voice so I've
wanted to face that too-hoo interested
who hopefully prove to myself that why
was their fear run using voice I would
think there would be fear around writing
something down that I would post on the
internet if you send it to me well
there's that too which is why I send you
fewer love letters than I used to write
but the writing I find is a viable
option it allows a certain degree of
predictability you can hone your message
and it can be asynchronous right you
don't have to respond in real-time right
and I think that with saying what needs
to be said in many of these cases I
wanted to see and feel the responses
from these people whether I was thanking
them and expressing gratitude or perhaps
making clear that's something that was
done or something that wasn't done for
me was not okay and that it's had
repercussions and that it's something
I've suffered through
and that I'm not looking for any
resolution I'm not looking for a
response but it's weighed very heavily
on me that I have kept this to myself
and felt like it was a secret that I
alone needed to carry so it's really and
I make that really explicitly clear to
in a lot of these conversations that I'm
saying it just because I want to feel
free after having said it there's no
expectation of a solution a resolution
behavioral change none of that and that
I'm just looking for an opportunity to
voice something yeah so I've done almost
all of it via voice that's great yeah it
sounds like it's such a freeing thing
like if you didn't how many of those did
you have to do it you still have more to
go through or is it up there are its it
sounds like Arya Starks List
exec it's it's not a long list it's it's
really in certain moments whether it's
like taking a bath or going for a long
hike I will have these moments of
clarity I'm like oh yeah that thing
there was never any resolution right it
doesn't have to be a big guy doesn't
have to be a big deal it's also not like
you know I'm hunting down the guy five
years ago cut me in line at Starbucks to
the confession I'm not doing that I'm
looking for the the the anchors that I
at some point never never was able to
reel in if that makes sense right it's
like there was something that was never
completed there was a sense of no
resolution and my resolution just to
make it super clear I don't mean
solution
I mean closing the loop moving right
enter like from an emotional standpoint
so yeah I think we could all think of
one or two of those that we all have
like I have one top of my mind where I'm
like huh I should go back and close that
loop you know it's like you know did did
you do something to also apologies I've
also
issued issued apologies and given
apologies to folks so it could be
apologizing for something you did that
at the time you felt you were in the
right and doing and looking back you're
like that was stupid even even perhaps
you were in the right but the tone and
the delivery you used was really
aggressive or mm-hmm unnecessarily
heavy-handed it's like okay then that's
that's a closed loop or a loop that you
should that you could benefit from
closing right and it's it's been a it's
been an exercise for me and a very
valuable exercise I'm not saying it
applies to everyone but for me Gerry's
questions have been really important
because they it for me they tie together
and let me explain so let's take what am
I not saying that needs to be said or
that should be said and then you have
number one on my list you know how am i
complicit in creating the conditions I
say I don't want well yeah if by not
speaking truth in some
fashion I have developed resentment
towards someone right whose fault is
that one could argue that it's my fault
because I kept that inside in which case
I'm complicit in creating this sort of
emotional terrain that breeds resentment
like I am complicit in creating this
condition so an often times sometimes
those are in your own head like you've
made up this story of why this person is
this way and then you have the
conversation or like oh I'm actually the
[ __ ] I did I just understood where
they were coming from you know
absolutely and I will say also that in
almost every instance whatever I
expected in these conversations to
happen
whatever I thought the most likely
response was was not the response and
that has been fascinating right I'm like
well that person is this type of person
when I say X they are likely to respond
with a B or C and when you use very
thoughtful delicate language like the
story I've created in my own head is
suddenly people you think you know
really well can surprise you and that
has opened up a whole new level of depth
in many relationships in my life having
these conversations that's been the
Icebreaker that's been months or years
overdue it's been it's been really
really quite profound I'm gonna name a
couple of other things real quick that
were realizations I had when looking
back over the next 10 years and the next
10 years well time traveling back to the
future the last 10 years because I have
four books right for our body for our
chef's tools to tighten strap Dementors
then got the TV and got all these
different projects a couple of things
we're getting out of the maybe hyper
emotional stuff happy to go back but for
our chef since that was an experiment
and distribution where Amazon publishing
was boycotted by everyone Barnes and
Noble Indies big-box retailers
and this was reiterated for me with some
of my television experiences is you need
to really understand or ideally control
distribution and the only way that
you're gonna do that very often is by
financing and owning whatever you
produce yeah Foles is going to say that
. that's it like if you are not paying
for it you are not going to have if you
are a person tickity perfectionist like
me the degree of control that you will
want particularly when it comes to
choosing distribution because I've I've
had these these projects that have ended
up being things I'm extremely proud of
but they're locked in a vault somewhere
from a from a distribution standpoint
that's been very very painful so I've
had to learn that lesson over the last
10 years multiple times and also this
seems so childish
it's embarrassing to admit but you're
gonna laugh get everything in writing
if if suppose tells you via email or
this or that yes we're planning on this
type of ABCDE it needs to be in the
contract and yeah and one thing that I
really liked as a frame for agreements
which only came up recently with Gary
Keller who's a huge real estate magnate
innovated a lot in that space based here
in Austin he said you should you should
view every agreement as a disagreement
because it's most important function is
to tell you what happened what happens
and what the options are if there is a
disagreement all right right so that's
been something I've learned repeatedly
and then the other question that I still
pay a lot of attention to that led me
from for our chef two years later
because I took a long break for me at
least from books to tools of Titan's was
what might this look like if it were
easy that's become a really important
go-to question for me because I think
that I pride myself on being able to
handle complexity and sometimes that
results in me coming up with some
what ridiculously unnecessarily complex
solutions to things where yeah the
easiest solution like rather than
spending the next year figuring out the
perfect wordsmithing so that I can
manually reply to everybody who asks me
about books and doing this and promoting
on the newsletter and doing the podcast
I thought maybe I just do a blog post
it's 200 words long that says I am not
reading any new books published in 2020
and 2020 is how I got to that was by
asking this question so those are a few
things that have come up for me
I'm curious one question I had about
your kind of this new decade going
forward you know when looking at your
career arc like over time and knowing
you since the 4-hour body and seeing the
focus and emphasis on biohacking and
wellness and health and nutrition and
cooking and then moving a little bit
more into you know mentors and and
interviewing other folks and then your
experience with psychedelics and it
seems like the last like you know 3 to 5
years has been really focused on
emotional well-being an improvement
they're going where do you when do you
eventually or are you still involved in
the kind of biohacking stuff and do you
see that like what's what's the next
decade look like for Tim you know before
you know you read your books and it's
about like optimizing testosterone and
like you know certain things in there
that like you know masturbating with
your offhand or ever like that you get
like the you don't talk about these
little hacks to get like this awesome
boost yeah yeah that was actually your
e-book on masturbating on the offense
that was a great experiment little stuff
like that in there but I mean I get the
wording wrong but you don't have talked
about and I'm just curious like what
what you know what are the next 10 years
look like for you on that front is that
something where you've kind of said
screw it I take like vitamin C now or
like what do you what are you doing
there yeah on the body hacking front
I've I've dramatically simplified for
the host of reasons number one is the
4-hour body at its time I think was
it was just given the reception and the
success of the book it was a it was a
bit of a category killer I mean it was a
very different book but there are many
people who picked up that torsion ran
with it who do all sorts of crazy
experiments things that I would not
necessarily do so I feel like there is a
there's a wealth of self experiment self
experimentation and and many different
folks who are continuing to biohack I
have continued to do experiments what
does your regimen look like today I'm
just curious like what do you wake up
and take just some of this up on the
supplements I take very very few
supplements I take right now the basics
are magnesium get an old man Oh bleep
yeah like while Mack teen specifically
so magnesium L three and eight which is
recommended by our friend earlier Peter
TIA and otherwise I've really tried to
minimize supplements and that's not
because I think they are bad I think
it's like saying drugs there is a very
wide spectrum of drugs and generally
speaking the greater the effect the
greater the side-effects and if you
don't know what the side effects are and
it has a very high amplitude effect then
you're just the sucker at the poker
table who doesn't realize he's the
sucker because there are very rarely
free lunches in biochemical enhancement
usually if dude yeah I mean I'm blown
away by that because there's someone
that's been in your house and seen your
medicine closet or cabinet back in the
day oh yeah you had I had a farm
hundreds of buying a farm that farms
like you could you could have sold out
of there I would pitch so like you have
you had everything Kimmy's bodega that's
right yep so I and I and there's still a
time and a place for that right so if I
were optimizing for a particular type of
competition and really
really focusing on say endurance
development at altitude or something
like that then I would have a particular
regimen I do supplement with protein at
this point I mean their sponsors of the
podcast but I vet everything that I've
turned down millions of dollars were the
sponsorships from supplement companies
but a scent protein made the cut so I
use the scent protein I use death let it
greens just for covering my bases
especially if I'm traveling to help
mitigate sickness when for instance I
did a Grand Canyon trip actually more
recently I did a 250 or 280 mile bike
trek mountain bike trek on the Hayduke
trail from because we started and I want
to say Grand Junction might be getting
that roughly off ending in Moab I took
two days off to ride in the service
truck because I was so destroyed but the
point being where we were staying at the
front end and the back end this is basic
Airport Hotel food
and I will use supplementation more as
its intended to supplement when my whole
food options are suboptimal right but I
do think supplements can become a crutch
for people who are not paying sufficient
attention to their whole food to their
sleep to other parameters right it
becomes a a band-aid to cover other bad
decisions so yeah but from a from a
biohacking standpoint I'm still
extremely interested in it what I'm but
I've shifted my focus a bit so if you
look at say for our body right we're
talking about hormones right
testosterone and so on growth hormone
and there are chapters on doing all
sorts of wacky things with different
hormones and vertical leap maximal speed
relative relative strength improvement
with deadlift all this craziness right
then you have 4-hour chef which was very
much cognitively focused and got into
different smart drugs and using
vasopressin to enhance short-term memory
and all this all this crazy [ __ ]
then if you look at the last let's just
call it five to six years for me the
fact of the matter is I'm still very
interested in biohacking but it starts
to get into some very very fascinating
alien terrain that Western medicine and
really no no single medical system or
scientific system explains very well and
that is use of compounds as one example
classical psychedelics like mescaline
psilocybin and so on but not limited to
those you could also include in that
group MDMA for PTSD compounds that seem
to exert an effect with
rapid onset and extremely long duration
of effects meaning in the cessation of
smoking studies that have been done so
nicotine addiction studies have been
done at Hopkins you have people who six
I want to say six or twelve months later
eighty percent of the subjects are still
non-smokers after two or three sessions
with psilocybin combined with
psychotherapy but nonetheless you're
looking at three sessions each of which
lasts let's call it four to eight hours
and the half-life of these drugs is very
well known nonetheless these these
paradigm and I do rarely use this word
but sort of paradigm-shifting mental
reorganization and these reformatting of
the belief systems and stories these
people use to govern their realities
have changed so fundamentally that their
behaviors remain changed even in the
face of extremely addictive compounds
like nicotine six or twelve months later
so one could argue that I'm still very
much in the biohacking game I'm just
going from the knowns right if we look
at testosterone like testosterone
whether that's naturally produced or the
injectables it's us Mississippi innate
or
and and any type of means of
administration or HCG or whatever these
things are all very well understood
right aspirin yeah very well understood
some of the smart drugs like hydrogen
very well understood and at least very
well studied so I'm moving from these
knowns into this area of unknowns with
psychedelics where we could
unlike the use of testosterone at least
at this point with the technology we
have access to fMRI and otherwise much
tighter study design now than say in the
50s we are in a position to to discover
fundamentally new ways of looking at the
mind and consciousness and therefore
reality as we experience it and that to
me is the money shot right everything
else that's like a slight refocus though
right cuz that's more of a focus on
brain and mental health and rewiring
that's done there versus say longevity
well I mean yes and no right so there's
there's longevity I do think that
psychedelics actually could offer
plausible mechanisms of action for
extending cognitive function that's a
whole separate conversation but I have
Alzheimer's and Parkinson's on both
sides of my family so my initial
interest as an undergrad in neuroscience
was purely self-defense I wanted to
learn as much as possible to help my
parents my family and yours truly to at
the very least delay the onset of are
you three four yeah oh you are okay see
you have the genetic marker that gets
you what you're like four or five times
more likely to get Alzheimer's I'm the
average person yep so if we're looking
at it from a software perspective right
I'm coded to have a much higher
predisposition to certain types of
neurodegenerative disease and
that it's it's that is the hand I've
been dealt so the question is how will I
play that hand and looking at say
Hopkins where all of this is led
especially as a nascent what I would
consider still a very nascent field the
ability to put in relatively small
amounts of money although I mean I've
committed a lot for me about three
million or four million dollars now to
scientific research related to
psychedelics and I should say that
psychedelics are tools in the toolkit
but really what I'm looking at is novel
treatments potential novel treatments of
what are considered intractable
psychiatric conditions right anorexia
highest mortality rate of any
psychiatric disorder miserable track
record in terms of effective treatments
freewill resistant depression
end-of-life anxiety say due to terminal
cancer diagnosis nicotine addiction
opioids opioids there's a yeah so at
Hopkins there are a number of studies
that we'll be getting underway at the
first Center for dedicated Center for
psychedelic and consciousness research
in the u.s. which is going to be based
they're looking at Alzheimer's looking
and opioid use disorder which means
opioid addiction effectively and so my
my shift has been a shift but I would
argue that and this is going to be a
fortune cookie
/ cliche that I'll use but it's not
about how many years I can put into my
life but also about how much life I can
put into my years so I think it's
important and it for anyone who's seen
my TED talk on fear setting or read my
post on titled some practical thoughts
on suicide I almost offed myself in
college and there are many people who
live a long time but are trapped in
these endless loops of self recriminate
adopt in the past and depression they're
trapped in the future and anxiety and I
would argue that that is not living at
least not as
I would like to experience it that is
surviving right that is being a physical
form that is not dead but that is not
the same as thriving so if we look at
the staggering growth of say opioid use
in the u.s. particularly synthetic
opioids if we look at the veterans
suicide rates many of which we are
comorbid with opioid use disorder but if
you look at say the number that I've
heard it may or may not be statistically
defensible but something along the lines
of 23 veterans per day committing
suicide if you look at the rates of
depression and substance abuse among
teenagers say there's cleric to my mind
are clearly societal factors at play
that are the perfect soil for producing
these types of coping mechanisms and so
for me yes the biohacking has shifted
but the same toolkit that I applied to
trying to optimize sex drive or
testosterone or whatever it might be
yeah the same literature review and
research that I had to do there has been
much improved and refined over the last
five years in particular to look at
psycho emotional health and I am really
really really optimistic and that's
coming from someone who thought he had
problems that were sort of personalized
and permanent unfixable let's put a
bullet in the head instead that which
yes something many people feel and I I
am now at this point extremely
optimistic about some of these new novel
treatment procedures ketamine is very
interesting has its own challenges both
psilocybin and MDMA have been granted
breakthrough therapy designation by the
FDA to expedite the the review process
so I'm cautiously optimistic but have
seen such a difference in my own life
and you've known me for a long time man
I mean you've known me since 2007 I feel
like fundamentally eight
different person today than I did six or
seven years ago yeah and I mean I can
definitely see it in you yeah I can tell
a difference for sure just the way that
you carry yourself even when you
keyboard our house like couple months
ago Daria was like Tim just like he's
just carries himself differently you're
just like a lot more relaxed at you know
that ease at ease and that's why I
actually had trouble preparing for this
conversation because looking at 2020 I
was like man well I guess people are
gonna expect me to have like a million
resolutions but I don't and I have a
handful of things but what I've realized
is that for me at least like peace is
not found through understanding right
peace is not found through more striving
peace is not found through more
achieving peace is found through greater
acceptance that's what I have found for
myself and what does that mean it
doesn't mean accepting shitty things and
allowing bad behavior and awful
atrocities or trends to continue it just
means taking time to recognize that in
most circumstances you are okay things
are okay and allowing yourself to kind
of bask in that does that make sense
yeah it's a missense dude I get it you
know and I feel like you if also
especially in the last I want to say two
years and I don't know two or three
years how much that is kids how much of
it is going through programs like you
did is it Michael singer yeah he what
the untethered soul but the he has won
on surrender that's phenomenal render
but I've noticed that you
still get a lot done right you're still
very engaged with creative projects but
you seem to me I was very impressed with
this and I mentioned it to my girlfriend
last time we were at your place I said
it's really nice to wake up go upstairs
and see Kevin just sitting with his kids
drinking a cup of tea or a cup of coffee
completely unrushed yeah right it's
funny that that's on my list of things
that I had to talk about today I wrote
down not everything has to be done today
patience yeah and I think that when you
think of things having to be done today
and everything has to be done today
then you're anticipating the feeling of
completion and when you're anticipating
that it's not you're not enjoying what's
happening right now yeah because you're
thinking like I'll feel so much better
when my to-do list is done I'll feel so
much better when I complete this project
you know and the thing that I've
realized over the last couple years I
than anything has been that I have over
the last you know 10 years or even you
know in founding dig in 2004 and staying
with that for seven years I never
enjoyed it yeah I never was able to
because it was just like oh I got a run
I got to do this I have to make this
have to launch this I have to grow
faster I have to do all this today I
look back and I'm like wow there was no
joy I mean there was little winds and of
course certain things brought me joy but
it was so rushed that I was never here
I what my head my brain was always
focused on tomorrow yeah and so you know
just having that patience and just being
able to exhale and realize that dude
we're gonna miss all of life if we don't
enjoy the day-to-day dance of it all you
know and that that's that's what I
strive to do I don't always do that but
that's that's been my hopefully that is
something that I will focus on over the
next you know five to ten years is just
really taking it all in
and smiling you know and spending and I
think kids helps it done that's why I've
been pushing you to have kids yeah I
know you and I have been trying to try
and it doesn't doesn't seem to be
working it's not okay damn it the the
the focus on not rushing is one I think
is very important at least for me and
that for me luxury in a way more than
anything else is the feeling of being
unrest right and I think that that is a
goal of sorts as a litmus test is has
many many ripple effects that are
beneficial which come out of that and
there's a book I'm reading right now I'm
not done with it yet but called already
free which I suspect is probably quite
similar to some of Michael singers work
that just came out this year right uh I
don't know the date it was recommended
I'm just kidding and just kidding that's
behind did not come out this year it it
was recommended what's it called again
I'm gonna look at that already free and
okay it combines Western psychotherapy
with Buddhist practice and concepts from
Buddhism which if you told me ten years
ago what I just said I would have
vomited a little bit into my mouth and
said yeah I've been to those bookstores
too with all the crystals and the
dreamcatchers and there are thousands of
those books and I just don't have time
to sort through what is [ __ ] and
what might have validity but this book
was recommended to me by a top tier
therapist who has she would never say
this but she's saved the lives of
hundreds or maybe thousands of people
she's she's incredibly adept and she
recommended this book to me and because
she has found it compelling and I'm
gonna butcher it but do you have the
name of the author up in front yeah it's
a Bruce Tift MA lumped oh wow it could
be if you just search for Bruce if but
already free is is the title of the book
and I I've found this book to be very
actionable under a compelling and one of
the apologize to the author if I'm
misremembering this but one of the the
the practices are steps that he will
often take with clients is
is the fault something along the lines
of the following if they complain that
say they're their boss never recognizes
them therefore they have struggles with
self-worth and this this this this and
this and that is a complaint that they
have something they'd like to fix that
comes up continually in therapy is he
will try to get to them to the point
where they are willing to accept that
they could have that feeling for the
rest of their lives unresolved and will
guide them through thought exercises and
hypothetical scenarios so they get to
the point where they are willing to
accept that is a possibility they will
never get rid of that and what often
seems to happen and I've noticed this
for myself is that they're then able to
let out this big exhale because it's no
longer mandatory that they push this
boulder up a hill and fix the problem
and all of a sudden their experience
changes mm-hm and that at that point
they become too fit they become able to
think more clearly and respond less
reactively
because they've accepted that if that
were to happen they're going to survive
there will still be moments of joy they
can still build other valuable
relationships and it just reframes the
whole thing so I have found that to also
and it is a close cousin to a lot of the
fear setting but I think that that type
of reframe can be very very powerful and
for me a lot of it comes back to good
questions right which is why I collect
questions why I enjoy asking questions
why I enjoy borrowing questions from
from other people and
I would say also looking back in the
last ten years for my entire life I
viewed self-love I think as
self-indulgent in the sense that I felt
it would be narcissistic and selfish and
unproductive to feel or embrace or
cultivate self-love in any way and then
fact the way to drive myself was to
constantly pick apart everything I was
or did in a very brutal fashion in terms
of internal monologue and I think that
that is part of what drove me so close
to the edge in college is that incessant
abusive inner voice and I got a lot done
you know I did a lot of things and at
the end of the day who the [ __ ] cares
really right like in 200 years we're all
dust no one's gonna remember us it
doesn't matter right so great I got a
better grade on my junior term paper who
the [ __ ] cares right at the end of the
day that voice almost drove me to
extinguish myself so what I've also
found is that looking back at the last
10 years like how you treat yourself
affects it it in some way influences how
you treat other people so if you are
violent and angry towards yourself there
will be an element of violence and anger
towards other people whether it comes
out really obviously or it comes out in
the form of like resentment and
complaining and passive aggressiveness
it's going to manifest so spending time
with jack Kornfield
has had a huge impact on me and this was
a few years ago when I first met Jack
he's a very famous meditation teacher
wonderful human being walks the walk
there are a lot of posers in the
mindfulness meditation world a lot of
people who
really are of the do what I say not what
I do school if you look under the hood
jack is so adept and as such an
incredible toolkit also as a clinical
psychologist for helping veterans that
adolescents were self harming and
cutting he's very skilled and we had a
wait a conversation at one point and he
said something that stuck with me and
I'm gonna paraphrase it because the
exact words are important but the gist
is and that is if your compassion
doesn't extend to yourself it's
incomplete and that seems so obvious
right but I do think that a lot of
people who pride themselves on being
achievers spend the vast majority of
their time whipping themselves what do
you think I mean I think everyone has
that internal dialog and some days it
can be more intense than others in terms
of being critical or for me it's it's
not so much critical myself as it is
just ruminating on certain thoughts and
like over and over again I have had a
lot of that how did you break out of
that like what was it is something that
you still struggle with today like if
someone's listening to this they're like
oh my god that describes me to the tee
like I have all these I'm constantly so
harsh on myself what are the steps that
someone would take well some are easier
to recommend than others I've done a lot
of really wild stuff and some very very
aggressive stuff and it's not to say
that all tools will work for all people
but I do think that there are certain
books that have had a large impact on me
that have helped other people and in
fact now that I think about it I believe
that one of them radical acceptance by
Tara brach was recommended to me by
Daria which surprised the hell out of me
because Daria is very sharp
scientifically minded very skeptical and
least back in the day my experience with
Daria was that anything remotely woowoo
or hand-wavy she was just like talk to
the hand not interested right so when
she recommended this book very generic
title and the subtitle I can't remember
at the moment but radical acceptance by
Tara brach and I thought oh my god like
has Daria had a had a frontal lobotomy
like what happened I don't know how this
book she has it would make it through
her filter and it was incredibly helpful
so radical acceptance self-acceptance
making peace with parts of us aspects of
ourselves emotions we have grown to
believe our negative or unwanted you
know reconciling re integrating yourself
in a way is is a worthy goal and I think
I've largely succeeded I still have my
moments where I beat myself up but it is
less than 5% of what it was five or six
years ago I feel like this could be a
good book for you honestly
oh it I've already been I have a
Scrivener file with hundreds of
thousands of words already put together
oh really it's not in book form but I
this this this is the book that I want
to work on and this is the book I talked
about in my episode with Greg McEwan as
the thing that I feel I need to do and
for 2020 and I started this already at
the end of 2019 but I'm getting back to
writing regularly on the blog for that
reason it's sharpening the soft so that
when I really sit down to put together
prose I want it to be as good as
possible and this is definitely this is
definitely a calling I feel called to do
this in part because I've seen the
effects not just through using books but
certainly practices I think that Byron
Katie's the work can be very helpful it
can be also a little
using but Byron Katie is the work as a
means of testing assumptions and stories
that you tell yourself because stress
testing them and as an exercise being
forced to come up with evidence or
examples that counter your statement not
your belief is really can be very
eye-opening especially when done in a
group context then you have certainly
meditation with without a doubt
especially in my case when combined with
either entirely cutting out caffeine or
dramatically cutting out caffeine mm-hmm
I that is that is non-trivial for me
that's that's tough to do i I did that
about a month and a half ago I I'd
wanted to go one month without caffeine
and I I was winning myself up a little
too aggressively yeah and I started
getting those horrible caffeine
headaches here but but I was able to do
it then I I actually just switched to
decaf coffee which has a tiny trace
amount of caffeine but that stuff is
horrible there's no good decaf coffee
out there if somebody out there this
listening and knows of some please let
me know somehow just tweet at me I
really appreciate it yeah it's it's I
tend to use my time in nature or time
fasting which I'll often do in nature
but Mike if I'm spending a lot of time
in nature let's just take this last Utah
trip as an example unlike a day like
today where I am mostly sitting inside
if I'm mostly sitting inside I have an
oral fixation and I'll just drink iced
tea and coffee all day because it's
sitting in front of me and I'm looking
for a fidget just like I fidget with my
you know pen and flick my pen around
it's a fidget whereas if I'm in Utah and
I want to get to fresh powder and I'm
waking up early I'll have a cup of
coffee in the morning but then I'm on
the slopes or outside for at least a few
hours when I am consuming nothing but
water and what I realize after a few
days of that is that I feel like I've
been meditating twice a day for a month
but
and perhaps being outside and skiing and
so on is a form of meditation in and of
itself but suffice to say often I've
thought to myself you can either
meditate once or twice a day for two
weeks or just cut your caffeine
consumption down to one cup of coffee a
day and the results are very often the
same if you come if you combine them all
the better but I've never heard of
anyone obtaining enlightenment via less
caffeine you know then you might be
there's always a first there's always a
first I'm happy to be the first
non-caffeinated monkey shot into space
on the quest to enlightenment through
abstinence but and I I don't like making
a recommendation with the following but
it would be the elephant in the room if
I left it out psychedelics responsible
supervised facilitated sessions with
psychedelics have provided a reset slash
reformatting that is very difficult to
achieve via other means I don't think
it's impossible but it's very
challenging and I simply have no way I
have theories but no way to explain
quite how profound and lasting the
changes can be or how they're produced
it's still very poorly understood what
we do know is that in some cases say
with psilocybin the toxicity is
exceptionally low I mean is it as far or
less than say acetaminophen tylenol and
many other things so I do not take this
stuff every afternoon it's not a I try
not to be a hammer looking for a nail I
do not think these drugs are panaceas I
do think there are significant risks
possible risks for those who say have a
family history of schizophrenia and you
can make very poor decisions you can
make dangerous decisions while under the
influence which underscores the
importance of facilitated supervised
sessions
but these compounds have been integral
to providing enough slack in the system
and different perspectives from which I
can look at myself as an observer right
it's it can be very difficult to see
your own stories right because like your
entire reality like what we look at what
we hear is is not the only reality right
it's like we're brains are interpolating
and filling in a lot of gaps as we use
generic concepts and stories to
interpret and make sense of everything
around us so I'm not the first person
come up with this metaphor but it's it's
like trying to look at the lens of your
own eye as you're looking through the
lens you just can't do it
but psychedelics in proper setting with
supervision can in some instances
provide you the ability to sort of
rotate out or above and really do a
radical self-assessment that shows you
where your blind spots are and it shows
you where your stories and your software
out of date but I do not recommend
people break the law if we want to talk
about side effects the legal side
effects can be significant I mean you
can you can go to jail for a long time
if you possess or distribute these
compounds they are currently schedule
one and this is why I'm dedicating I've
dedicated more capital and energy to
psychedelic research than anything else
in the last few years and it is I want
to say at least a it is close to or more
than all of the capital I've invested in
startups over whatever it was a the
almost ten year period so if this when
this becomes a legal form of therapy are
we going to see Tim five
branded psychedelic pop-up shops around
the country tim ferriss psychedelic
treatment mall kiosks yeah right next to
buy it directly from five bullet Friday
right next to Express spawn the airport
right why travel sober when you could
would you ever be involved in anything
like that though like I mean all kidding
aside there is there's more interests on
the research side it's not just a
question of interest it's a question of
maintaining a neutrality so I can be
more effective and I don't I don't want
people to question my motives which is
the same reason by the way I did not
invest in or create any supplement
companies before for our body I could
have made tens of millions of dollars
doing that easily and I knew that
because as you know I mean I used to own
sports nutrition companies so yeah I
know how those businesses work I could
build one very easily I have access to
all the right people and I didn't do it
because I didn't want people to question
my motives I wanted to be as objective
as possible and for people to view me as
objective or as objective as possible
and in the world of psychedelics I don't
want to place any bets in a for-profit
capacity that would lead me to even
subconsciously exert bias in who I help
or what I help yeah and even if I could
make a for-profit bet that would not
affect my objectivity it would affect
the how others perceive me in the field
and that would inhibit my ability to
move the needle in a number of different
ways and last I will say and this is
this is this is also
vocabulary these are phrases that you
know Tim of 15 years ago would just be
disgusted by but he didn't know didn't
know what he didn't know this is a very
sacred space this is this is very in
some ways very sacred work it's it's
incredible when you witness what can
transpire for someone in a four to six
hour session and how completely their
conception of themselves and
relationships problems addictions can
change you feel like you're witnessing
something very special and you are
witnessing something very special
something very unusual that many people
hope their whole lives for and never get
and to that extent you and I have been
very fortunate and we've had all sorts
of advantages we've also had you know
certain disadvantages and we've made
lucky bets and we're in a position where
we don't have to make compromises we
don't have to make compromises to
generate income right like we're not
worried about how to pay the rent next
month and for that reason I like having
this entire field to be for me a a
capital off-limits a money off-limits
area in my life that makes sensing it's
just a it's just a complication that I
don't want and don't need and for that
reason I would be very surprised I'd be
very surprised if there was any Tim
Ferriss branded airports I get like he
asked there there may be outfits that I
assist in some way but I can't imagine
that I would ever tie financial
incentives or financial return to
anything that I do in this space I would
be disappointed myself unless something
very
very significant changes and I just
can't imagine quite what that would be
yeah and let's say I did something who
knows let's just say some gigantic
pharma company said will you advise us
on blah blah blah blah blah
as long as I could be convinced and this
this would be a long shot but let's just
say I was able I and my advisers were
convinced that they weren't just doing
this to sort of whitewash their sins and
provide a human riot shield for whatever
they were going to do and they wanted
advice of some type and they were
offering advisory compensation all of
the funds would have to go to funding
other types of research or to some other
recipient besides myself right perhaps
it goes into a foundation then gets
funneled directly into some related
cause that I care deeply about yeah it'd
be interesting to see how you could
think through that a little bit further
to kind of figure out if there is an
opportunity there that you could just
roll it into a complete non profit so
that you could participate in some of
the upside because obviously there are
going to be when this stuff does all
finally come around it is you know
stamped with the whatever it may be FDA
or whoever asked to stamp all the way
through to actually launching something
as a as a therapeutic product for the
consumer
they'll be multi-billion dollar business
is built on the back of this in some
capacity right there could be so there
definitely could be I think it's I think
it's gonna be a lot trickier than folks
expect and I hope that the current means
of administration meaning let's just
call it two or three sessions of two or
three active sessions there may be
placebo sessions but let's just call it
two or three active sessions with
long-term persistent effects I hope that
that does not get corrupted and replaced
with some type of analog that is or
close cousin that has then turned into a
maintenance tool in other words I hope
that the business priorities of drug
developers do not
affect the beautiful elegance of how
these tools can be used in such a way
they get converted into something that
needs to be used three times a week just
to get by and right i absolutely expect
there will be people who attempt to do
that but I would not want to I certainly
don't want to encourage that but there
could be a lot of money made and there
there are possibilities yeah my only
point was that I would rather see those
funds flow into someone's nonprofit like
your own yeah it would then go right
back into research then didn't have to
go to someone else but you know because
I didn't would entrust you with that
those those funds to do the right thing
yeah yeah I I and there are things I
want to do you know what idea that I had
for 2020 that I thought could be fun
which is not the same as a for-profit
business that then provides upside they
could be funneled into a non-profit
which is entirely possible I mean that's
what I'm doing with my foundation right
now but I've been I've been thinking
about doing it a high-end art auction
and I know people have done this in the
past I believe that I want to save
Leonardo DiCaprio has done a very good
job of this don't know you know
personally but the concept would be
getting pieces donated and I don't know
if a it's unlikely to me that Asafa B's
or Christie's or someone would would do
this they might but you have incredible
pieces of artwork donated by extremely
famous artists and to take the proceeds
and donate them to psychedelic research
for scientific let's do it this is you
could have this happen in two seconds I
know a ton of the auction folks from my
time at hideki okay great so if you want
to talk to any Christie's or Sotheby's
or Philips folks like this is this
happens already like for example there's
an auction each year that's called only
watch and every one of the high-end
watch manufacturers will create a
special one-off limited edition watch
are not limited edition but just one-off
and they raise you know tens of millions
of dollars for
I can't remember it's muscular dystrophy
or what what they actual cause is but
it's it's a wonderful cause and it
happens every year this could be that
for a psychedelic yeah so that excite
that excites thing right because you
have to because it could be no quiz it
could be paintings but it could also be
watches it could be anything and what's
so nice about that is people are bidding
there are certainly tax advantages for
people who are buying these items I
would imagine maybe maybe not but
nonetheless I mean they're going to a
good cause they are paying for one of a
kind or the very least highly
sought-after scarce items that have
value sustained value right so you're
not just kind of begging for money with
your hat out and what's so incredible
about the psychedelic research space
right now is that for 10 or 20 million
dollars I mean you can potentially bend
the arc of history
it's so nice n't and so much can be done
with so little that what would be
considered a drop in the bucket for
cancer research or any number of other
conditions could actually lead to
fundamental breakthroughs in an entirely
new field and not just breakthroughs as
it relates to a specific compound but
breakthroughs and how we begin to
understand how the mind and the brain
work right where is where is the seat of
consciousness does such a thing
anatomically exist I mean there are some
these are real questions that people are
investigating and I don't think we fully
appreciate the implications of figuring
some of that out I mean it's yeah it's
incredible it's so cool and there's so
many artists as you know who suffer from
absolutely oppression from exile it's a
no brainer it's this is like a perfect
match
like you have people that suffer with
something like that I mean where's you
you must know Banksy at this point right
I don't I would love to if you have a
connection I wanna I would love to
connect with Banksy for a million
reasons but I do not yet know banks
did go to his hotel yeah in the Middle
East which was amazing and pretty
incredible but I've studied him I know
of him I'm very familiar with his work
but don't know I feel like if we can get
him to commit a piece yeah that's a good
place to start that would be a great
place to start I mean and and there that
would be a great place to start there
are there a number of artists I find
absolutely incredible who you know were
they willing to participate would they
would act as the lead Domino that tips
over everything else right yes you don't
need you really just need that first
tenant right the first person who says I
believe in this and you know I haven't
reached out to anyone at this point but
one of my favorite artists in the world
is David Hockney he's so so incredible
you should check him out and there's
there's a wonderful documentary about
him called I want to say learning how to
see or the art of seeing that you should
check out and such a just seems like
such a beautiful human being very
well-spoken very humble and you know you
it should be doable right this is does
not strike me as insane let's talk
offline because I have some people you
should talk to I think we could make
this app and that sounds really cool
amazing amazing that's so exciting
the other thing that this is this is
jumping around topic wise but the other
thing I want to start doing this year is
something that I spoke with Nick
Thompson ages ago about and that is
hiring top-tier writers at say I think
that I think the I think the rate he
suggested was maybe $2 a word or
something like that but really paying
top dollar for good long-form
journalists to write pieces on my blog
like to invest to investigate topics
that would otherwise not get
investigated right I mean I'll give you
an example it's having a long
conversation with one of my closest
friends about a week ago about how the
preceding two days felt like two or
three
a lot of things had happened we'd moved
locations a lot we were spending a lot
of time in back country doing really
strong physical exertion and we both
noticed that the last preceding two days
seemed it was like oh my god that
happened two days ago it seems like
three weeks ago and yet there are also
weeks that go by where you're like what
the [ __ ] did I do this week like I know
I was sitting around doing stuff but
like it just went by like that yeah so
investigating let's just say it's one
example like investigating the expansion
of time right yeah okay what are the
what what does the science say what do
what if you want someone to pitch in on
that I will all throw some cash towards
that article - okay cool
yeah I've always been fascinated by this
I would love love to go in deep on that
I and it's like so let's get someone who
puts out just stellar stellar long-form
pieces that they can take some time on
right because I don't need this tomorrow
I'd love to have it tomorrow but if it
takes two months if it takes three
months I so be it I care more about the
quality but to have my let's just say to
have five of those any given time in
motion I it just seems like an excellent
use of money and yeah or there are
certain people I would love to have
profiles right like people who are doing
incredible weird things that are never I
don't I don't think would ever make it
onto the radar of some of the larger
publications I respect but they're just
they they already have I would imagine
an abundance of wonderful ideas and I I
have some say a leads and B suggestions
that could really help people gain
access to folks who otherwise wouldn't
be accessible or otherwise would never
get covered right
I mean it's that kind of thing it's like
alright let's do a human interest story
and do you have people in mind right on
the writer side that you would use cuz I
know we could probably reach out to Evan
medium I'm sure he's got a bunch of
great independent right
that you could get higher yeah I I spoke
with Nick about this I there are a few
writers I've worked with in the past who
I have found to be really really sharp
and also very ethical those two don't
always go together as we know which is a
huge bummer that's another thing I've
learned in the last 10 years is like
higher for reliability and
trustworthiness and attitude first lots
of skilled smart people out there who
may not have the best ethical compass so
you have to really guard against that
but there are there a number of writers
I've worked with who have done fantastic
work and they're there on the shortlist
they're kind of the the first list that
I have but there are so many there are
so many great writers out there and it
should be it should be possible to get
someone since I would be the editor so
to speak right and then I have no
delusions of thinking I'm David Remnick
of The New Yorker or anything I got I do
not think that I am the best editor in
the world but nonetheless it's my blog
so I have to look at this stuff and I'm
pretty good like I think I'm a very fair
and I've edited a lot of my friends
books because I can't not edit if they
give me something to review but I would
be bringing these people in because they
are extensively I mean almost certainly
better writers than I am so that's
really exciting to me just to just to
kick the tires and try it yeah that's
awesome and it's also one of those
examples of like one decision that
removes a lot of decisions like let's
just time is a non-renewable resource
I'm very confident I can make money back
if I need to let me just place some bets
and let people run yeah and then it's
like oh lo and behold like three months
later an email comes in got a first
draft or got a third draft whatever it
might be
they'll be very exciting to me yeah what
else if what else have you put on your
list of things to remember for 20/20 pay
attention to or just notes from the last
last decade I've got one but I'm gonna
I'm gonna hold on to it cuz you can talk
about it in a little in a little bit not
that we have to go for five hours but
anything else that comes to mind that
you'd like to mention yeah I mean I
think that one of the things that I look
back on that I'm I feel that I did quite
well over the last ten years was my
track record of investing in the public
markets and I think that you're my very
good I appreciate that
i-i've I think I know I have kind of
like put my formula down on paper so I
have a sense of what I how I am able to
take big risks without them feeling like
big risks and I think that's key for me
not to freak out and sell things off so
essentially what I've figured out is my
mixture of investments and for me you
know you've always heard that well I
mean there's that saying that I guess
most people think is is [ __ ] which
is probably true which is to hold your
age and bonds right like the old saying
is if you're 40 years old you should
have 40% of your net worth and bonds and
I have always liked having some security
like that I think that that is not a
wise strategy for young investors
because I think they are too heavily
weighted and safer investments when they
should be taking the most risk upfront
but now that I am into my 40s I don't
think of it as just bonds I think of it
as what are some safer investments that
I can't have that 40% in so that could
be you know higher yield bonds it could
be dividend paying stocks that are blue
chip you know dividend stocks that I I
hold in a basket or an index but the
thing that that exotic atoms exactly but
even my investment types but that
there's nothing that's all you can reap
ich that out this kind of stuff
in any investment book what I have done
that is different is that I've said that
20 percent of my net worth whatever that
may be is going to go into ultra risky
investments but only ones that kind of
soup to nuts I understand at a very very
deep level so that means these really
risky tech investments for me and that
has lead to you know early investments
in Bitcoin early investments in in Apple
you know I remember when Apple came out
with OS 10 the first version and I was
just blown away and I knew this was such
a brilliant new direction for the
company that was in 2001 the stock back
then was trading at a dollar 60 or so a
share which is just insanity but you
know more more recently in the last few
years that would be you know the
Shopify's and the Tesla's and things
like that but you know also avoiding
stuff I didn't understand I think it's
like the saying no like for example
everyone was jumping on Netflix you know
five years ago maybe even longer I
didn't understand it I didn't understand
how this wouldn't become just like the
music business and how it would be the
margins would be ultra-thin I had no
idea about creating original content
with those costs with the cost structure
for that would be it was something that
a lot of my friends were making
fantastic returns on but something that
I ended up not buying and I missed out
on that one but that's fine because I
was able to concentrate my bets on
things that products not only that I
used and enjoy but under understood
completely and that for me taking that
that 20% of my investments and focusing
them on things that I believed that
could truly have you know 25 - fixed yet
50x returns over the next couple decades
I think has been key in kind of growing
my mind net worth over time so we're
talking about or you're talking about
buy decisions all right how do you
decide what's your framework for
deciding when to sell things if you have
one and it could be any category or all
categories but you're somewhat famous
for telling me what you're going what
you're going to buy and then
not telling me six months later when you
sell it all yeah I mean I think that the
the thing is has the underlying no
that's true I think months later I'm
like oh man times like come on you're
like I sold that a year and a half ago
well well I I think like have the
underlying fundamentals of the business
changed you know and I think that if the
answer is yes then I consider selling if
the answer is no but you're seeing a
decline due to other market turbulence
then that's actually when I buy more so
if I see a big massive dip and it has
nothing to do the company but it was
just something that came out of Trump's
mouth like I'm going to tumble down and
pick up some more stock on sale right so
you know and then also working with your
tax accountant so you know when you
could take some gains off the table in
tax wise it makes sense for you
but I would say that you know I am even
more skeptical and scared of stocks like
Netflix today because I look at all the
other entrants in the market over the
that you know are both coming and have
recently launched whether it be Apple
TV's streaming services or you know the
dude Disney Plus or you know peacock
which is coming out there's because it's
gonna be so much competition for that 5
to $10 a month kind of cable plus plus
that it's it's a little frightening but
you know so it's that's how I you know I
look at shop well also I think there's
there's a couple things one what's the
total addressable market of this
business so you know how big is that is
the the TAM there and do they have room
to grow so Shopify today you know I I
can't
I'm not sure where they're at 50 some
billion dollar company they were around
five early on and actually dude Shopify
was the one that you're probably killing
yourself over yeah I am I mean it's a
terrible terrible decision well you know
that I am I'm history now I've I have
improved but I'm an adviser to them
before they went public when they had
eight employees so I was with them I
rode a not day one but very early and I
panicked sold a panic sold
and that was maybe right after lockup
expired so this would be like whatever
that is six months after IPO and I just
made a terrible terrible decision and
sold a bunch of it I'm curious what was
the underlying reason though with the
talking about when to sell yeah
like the business was was having great
numbers quarter-over-quarter like if you
looked at all the fundamentals there
look I mean granted they they're not
profitable but but revenue was
increasing you know cost of acquiring
customers was going down what was it
that that you freaked out about I don't
I mean I don't think that freak outs are
generally a rational decision I'm not
like well if a and if B and therefore C
and one two three four five freak out
you know it's not like that is at the
end of a long deliberation I think that
the gain since my cost basis was
effectively zero right my gain was such
that the absolute number of dollars was
enough to at the time move the needle
for me and provide a level of security
that I didn't want to risk it does get
doesn't mean that there were a bunch of
risks I just didn't know and I you never
know what you don't know listen do do
not do you know I mean though I was like
you know oh dude that there's there's
that first wave of I want to take care
of myself pay off my bills pay off my
house this is like something that's
gonna secure my future yeah that you
would just be fuel a foolish not to take
and I get that it sounds like that's
what you were doing yeah that's what I
was doing and the the challenge has been
and we'd have to spend a lot of time on
this because I think we're getting into
rarefied air here but updating that
script right because I it's not the only
example of meet panic selling and I
panic sold other things
I mean panic sold is very dramatic but i
emotionally sold other things
Alibaba you know I was invested early in
Alibaba there were pre IPO and all sorts
of companies that I sold once they at
once they went public and it has taken
a lot of reflection and training and
planning that's that's number one for me
have a plan right don't go into a fight
with no plan then get hit and try to
figure out your game plan have a plan
going in so I've done that in the last
few years and I've not I've not panicked
sold or emotionally sold anything in the
last few years that's a lot easier to
say of course now that I have more
security but the point is even after the
point that I had more security I was
still I had not updated my OS right my
operating system was still like Windows
95 like panic panic crash panic crash
and I had to become aware of that before
I could change anything that make sense
yeah so you are a hundred times better
than I am in the public markets and
you've been very comfortable in the
public markets for a very long time from
from my perspective at least what I've
seen I mean you're a very rare breed of
investor because you are successful
across many different classes and many
different assets so you can go super
early stage I mean white paper early or
back of the napkin early all the way up
to mature public and I've seen you hit
homeruns in almost every every every
band of of investment terms of size and
also in terms of Technology it's it's
been it's been very impressive to watch
and I have to first admit to myself lest
I get my face ripped off that I'm not
you right
like I just have a different a different
way of approaching this stuff so yeah I
mean dude that you'll you'll laugh at
some of the grammar I write you in
emails so we all have our strengths some
of the things that I produce on other
fronts are laughable so you know I think
it's just kind of knowing what those
pieces are and and and playing To Your
Strengths you know yeah yeah played it
you can you can you can [ __ ] up a lot is
long
you play to your core strengths and make
a few good decisions I have made once a
year once every few years in the startup
investing game right like you can if you
hopefully they're not all predicated on
luck but if you have a decent process
right like you said you've missed out on
Netflix doesn't matter right like if you
write hit a home run you can strike out
if you hit a few home runs that are real
home runs right which you have you can
strike out a whole lot and that is when
you expect to you know it's like or
better yet the miss out of the gate you
can miss out that's a better way to put
it like you can pick you can wait for
the fat pitches and if you have rules
and certain systems which I've seen you
use which has been the impressive part
right if someone's just consistently
lucky I can't model that right and I
know those people - you and I both know
those people where it's like yeah all
right that article paints them is genius
but we all know they like they like
flipped a coin after drinking about
tequila and then like here we are so I
can't model that type of dumb luck and
there are some people who just seem to
be hardwired for incredible luck I don't
know what that's about we both know a
few of those to where it's just like pot
of gold falling out of the sky into
their lap every two years I just don't
know what that's about and then there
are the people who have rules and they
have systems and they have criteria and
I think you've done really well with
that so that's that's something I've
always watched with with admiration and
that is something that I've tried to
model but not by duplicating all of your
rules but simply having rules certainly
helped yeah it helps a lot yeah and I
mean I think that the the one thing I
want to emphasize on that last little
piece that we talked about in the
investing side the reason why 80% of my
stuff is in you know standard boring
index funds bond funds things like that
is because I know how risky the rest of
it is and you know I expect to lose a
lot of it so I would never advocate well
first of all I'm not I'm not in the even
in the position to give investment
advice I'm not legally allowed to but I
wouldn't I would advocate you know
investing more than you can lose because
you never know because there's so many
other factors you have the best company
on earth and you could have a downturn
in the market that's gonna last a decade
and you're still gonna be underwater and
so it's you know you always have to
factor that in as well
yeah I'm still I would consider myself
super conservative but not and I also
want to emphasize or maybe clarifies the
right word that you talk about ultra
risky right 20% ultra risky and it's
true that each of those bets you place
independently could be considered ultra
risky but you maybe you could speak to
this but I mean you also have a
portfolio approach and certain
advantages right informational advantage
and so on I'm not talking about any
public stuff but with with these super
early-stage companies with different
types of of currencies and so on I mean
cryptocurrencies and blockchain ins and
whatnot that you have you think about
portfolio construction and you think
about allocation you think about that
sizing right so then these individually
ultra risky bets when viewed in total
underscore the possibility that each of
them could say return the fund so to
speak right right so even though it's an
ultra risky it's it's a collection of
ultra risky assets the way that you
approach it while still risky certainly
stands a very high likelihood of success
right that's right yeah I mean that's
the classic venture rule that you know
it depends on whose math you're looking
at but you know 80 80 80 plus percent of
the deals that you do will go to zero
you know but the ones that do make it
you're hoping are the massive you know
thousand x kind of fund makers that that
to you that you can find especially the
really early-stage but yeah that's
that's part of part of getting
comfortable
all that is saying goodbye and not
taking it you know when things don't
work out and and not taking it
personally just realize it's the
riskiest thing that you can do and some
of the biggest mistake I see angel
investors make without a doubt is they
go out and do two deals they go out and
do three deals you know they'll say I
would much rather and this is how I
started out in the early days I went out
and placed five to ten thousand dollar
bets which I'm from an Angels point of
view is is really minimal dollars
because you know most Silicon Valley
angels are doing 25 to 100 K you know
chunks when they invest in a start-up I
didn't have that kind of money but I
knew the math and the math is that most
of our gonna go to zero so if that's the
case rather than have two companies at
25k apiece and say I'm done I'd rather
you know go out and have a whole dozen
of them at a much lower you know five to
ten thousand dollar kind of range and
have a greater chance that I will find
one of those crazy
unicorns it's going to return all the
rest of them all right so our cover for
the rest of them so that whenever I meet
someone that's looking to get into that
side of investing on the angel slide
it's always do more at with less dollars
in and then if you have the opportunity
to buy up in the future with pro rata
and you do see something that looks like
it's going to win you could because
you're already on the cap table you can
you know go in and purchase more shares
and future rounds of financing yeah
we're getting we're getting into the
nitty-gritty here well yes that could be
a whole separate conversation on
reserving a portion of your annual
budget for follow on with the pro rata
and all that but we want we can save
that for for our next random show you
know one thing that a last little thing
I will say that I think is is more
broadly applicable is you mentioned like
how do you decide when to sell and this
could be applied to public market
investing which most people are
comfortable with you know when your
allocation in that in that risky ultra
risky category outpaces and outgrows
we're all of a sudden that was 20% but
now it's actually 40 percent of your
portfolio then you need to rebalance and
that's that's when you could do that you
know the most fun is when you're ultra
risky
has you locked up so all of a sudden
you're like 90% you can't sell a goddamn
thing that's always a really stress-free
experience very important that is an
important point and what should we close
with any last thoughts I mean one one
takeaway that I've had from last ten
years and I have actually become much
better at this much better at following
my own advice remember Sam Harris once I
think he said to me or maybe you wrote
it somewhere but that you know wisdom is
largely taking your own advice
yeah there's a quote and I can't
remember the attribution somebody on the
internet can certainly tell us and I'll
put it in the show notes but that Living
Well is the best revenge
that quote has really been important to
me in the last few years and it comes
back to what what we were discussing or
what I was saying much earlier about
treating myself with anger and trying to
really replace that with more acceptance
and understanding and compassion which I
was focused outward I never really
focused it inward and a byproduct of
that meaning being less angry with
myself was trying to cultivate directing
less anger at other people also and I
was never a yelling screams throw plates
against the wall kind of guy but I would
feel intense anger when I was wronged or
felt wronged right and I mean if you've
been in the business world long enough
or if you've had enough relationships
like you've been [ __ ] at some point
and not not in the good way and I would
get very I would get very upset and I
would fantasize
I wouldn't always actualize but I'd
fantasize about the kind of eye for an
eye
type retaliation and the reality was
that that I very very rarely indulged in
that but rarely to guys I very rarely
difficut are very rarely took eyes as
Colonel Hackworth was his first time I'm
blanking once that sometime is it is
entirely appropriate to smash a mosquito
with a sledgehammer or something like
that or smash a flower with a
sledgehammer I think there is a time and
place for that don't get me wrong
but you know one doesn't want to set
precedent in some unfavorable way but
the point being that I've been I've
become much better and I'm not going to
mention this person by name but very
well-known person has as a reminder on
his screensaver on his laptop let it go
and this is a very accomplished person I
actually consider him to be very Zen and
emotionally resilient and calm
nonetheless he has that reminder let it
go on his desktop and I have realized
tying in this energetic management that
like Living Well is the best revenge if
someone's really [ __ ] you and they're
that person chances are they're not very
happy right and that's not always the
case there are some super aggressive dr.
evil narcissists [ __ ] who are quite
happy I hate to tell people out there
but they do exist nonetheless a lot of
the people who do awful things or break
their word whatever are pretty miserable
and letting them wallow in their own
misery and not engaging because it will
contaminate your experience has been
really key for me letting it go to the
extent possible right and and just like
Living Well is the best revenge has
really stuck with me right like the best
thing I can do is yeah live your life I
think what you just said was is really
it's interesting in that the way I've
always looked at it is if someone is
being very verbally aggressive with you
or angry or trying to push their energy
on to you if you take that and carry it
on and then release it to other people
you're just furthering their agenda of
spreading that that energy and it's it's
letting it go is just the ability to
actually set them free in a way you're
releasing that negative energy and
you're just like letting it dissipate
and it's such a freeing thing yeah you
know it's a beautiful thing if you think
of it like that you you've taught me a
lot with this in certain instances I
remember I got attacked by some some
troll as trolls we'll do many years ago
long time ago yeah I think well let's
see you might have a different example
but what and you said something like
yeah Tim do you do you really want to
engage in a fight with someone with
infinite time and I was like no I don't
when you phrase it that way like
absolutely not and you've given me
because of course coming out of coming
out of Digg and sort of early days you
had far more mileage with ya online yeah
I don't know if you remember this but I
think I told you also that I was like
when was the last time you've left a
negative comment on somebody's blog I've
been like [ __ ] you and somebody's blog
and like anonymously and it's like I
don't think I've ever done that yeah
because you're not that kind of person
Yeah right think of like the type of
person that is engaging with you here
and you don't need to it's just the the
one thing people don't realize about the
internet and that I learned through a
school of hard knocks is that just like
in society if you were to go and put 500
people in a room there are gonna be some
[ __ ] in that room I'm like
completely dicks that are mean-spirited
people that want to see other people in
misery the Internet is no different like
you get a group of people thousands
hundreds of thousands and there are
groups of very evil people yeah you
could if you know that then you could
just be like oh that's just one of those
evil people you know yeah yeah exactly
it's you know when you walk by them on
the sidewalk you may not notice but
they're there and I've seen another
quote that is kind of stuck with me and
I'm blanking on the attribution this is
a very famous quote but the paraphrase
is you know don't wrestle with pigs
because it just makes it makes you
filthy and it makes the pig happy and
it's just interesting and it's like yeah
like there's there's there's there's
nothing to be there's very little bit to
be gained from engaging with that so
yeah so my final quote for the day on my
side since you gave yours is from that
Michael singer course I took on
surrender which i think is a phenomenal
video course but he says something in
there that stuck with me where he says
serve the moment which I thought was
really interesting just this idea of
being so present that you're just
serving that moment in time it's just a
beautiful thing if you can pull it off
how do you how do you use that I like I
like the I like these connotation of
that but did you use it with yourself
yeah I just think like where's my head
right now you know am I really giving my
focus and attention and brain space to
what's going on right now am i serving
the people around me to the fullest at
this point in time and that can mean
simple things from paying attention to
my daughter when she's playing and
engaging with that versus being on my
phone yeah you know to worrying about
something or thinking about something in
the future that may or may not happen to
you know wanting to gouge somebody's eye
out like we mentioned like those are
that's not serving the moment that's
serving at the imaginary land you know
it's fighting with sock puppets yeah he
and I
I really meant it earlier when I said I
was I was really struck because you've
seen me through many chapters I've seen
you through many chapters over many
years and there have been times when
I've seen you and this is the contrast
right I've there were there was a time
when if you were sitting down with sort
of nothing no project to work on I would
see you on your phone and when I was
home with you I came up and you're just
sitting there sipping tea looking at
your daughter playing with blocks or
whatever she was doing unrushed and
fully paying attention and that might
sound quaint
it might sound simple but if we look at
the technological forces and the
financial incentives and the funding and
market caps of these companies and the
armies of PhDs who are attempting to do
just about anything to make that
impossible it becomes all the more
noteworthy I think in all the more
valuable to have practices and reminders
that help you to have those kind of
moments
and yeah absolutely I'm happy for you
man it's it's been really nice to see
you same dude I mean I didn't notice we
didn't say this on this show earlier but
I'm really stoked whoo with your
girlfriend now that shall go unnamed
she's amazing I got a chance to hang out
with her and meet her you know when
you're out here and it's it's really
cool to see you happy and and it's it's
been fun it's I'm excited for you to
have babies soon so that's all I'll say
well you know it may not be that far off
we shall see we shall see but they say
when I see your face and hear your voice
brother as always please give give my
love to the fam and you want to share
any any particular resources or point
people anywhere if they'd like to learn
what you're up to or see where yeah I'd
say most of stuff I publish I do on
Instagram so I'm just Instagram Matt
Kevin Rose and then yeah definitely
check out the the iOS app les le SS les
drinking I think it'll help you
those of you out there that want to be a
little bit more mindful about the
beverages you consume it's just a fun
little little project we're working on
and zero to four intermittent fasting we
did we hit I don't even think I told you
this we hit 1.3 million monthly fasters
now not fast but people fasting people
on zero that's in credits yeah we added
three hundred thousand people this last
30 days Wow so it's nuts I need your
help with my email list
that's incredible congratulations and
I'm excited for 2020
I'm really excited about and
yeah I don't I don't have much everybody
can find me a Tim dot blog and check out
the writing I'm gonna be doing more
writing certainly love the podcast and
we've continued to do that but in
service of eventually getting to the
point where I'm working on this book on
healing and psycho-emotional dynamics in
a very concrete way I mean it's not
going to be highfalutin and conceptual
they'll be like in the trenches with
some crazy crazy crazy crazy [ __ ]
stories I mean if you imagine kind of
for our body but for minded the mind and
emotion it's it would be like that but
much crazier much are using for our and
anyway I think I think I think I'm
retiring the for our troops are retiring
the for our Jersey yeah I just like I
still get joy out of it whenever I see
four hours somewhere like I said when I
saw the for our cleaners just gonna sent
you a photo of it yeah I remember that
part or whatever known for that forever
yeah well you know we we think we think
we know what we're doing and then we're
like oh my god the blessing and the
curse that will chase me forever here it
is exactly but you know they're they're
certainly far far worse far worse
prefixes so I'll take it for now but
love doing the random show man let's do
more of these and yeah let's uh let's
meet up in person before too long let's
do it sounds good
you